foreign
YouTube channel
in today's video we're going to be
talking about Google ads and how to
advertise on Google we'll be talking
about what is Google ads how do you set
it up why would you use Google ads we're
going to do a demo of Google ads and
we're going to look at things like
optimization and how to track your
results but before we go into that let
me quickly introduce myself I am Mark
campman I am your digital navigator for
this video and by the way don't forget
to like this video or subscribe to our
YouTube channel by clicking down below
right so when you are setting up your
brand and you need to make sure you
reach the Right audience with the best
results then there's only one place you
can go to and that is Google ads one of
the largest advertising platforms that
you can find online
yeah so in today's session we're going
to be talking about what is Google ads
why do you use Google ads what are the
benefits I'll be giving you a demo of
Google ads on how to set it up and how
to create your first ad and then we're
going to look at how do you measure your
Google ads what are the things you want
to match your measure and how do you
optimize your ads so you're getting
better results from your investments in
Google ads
so let's look at what Google ads is all
about where can you find it what are
Google ads and where do they show so
first of all it's very important to
understand that there are two forms of
Google ads
yeah there is the Google search ads and
there are the Google display ads so the
search ads they show on the Google
search results page and the display ads
they show on websites and there are
thousands if not hundreds of thousands
of websites that have an agreement with
Google to show Google ads and those
websites get a small compensation for
every time Google shows a Google ads on
their website
now within those search ads and website
ads there are different versions but
we'll come through that later for now
very important for you to understand
there are Google search ads and there
are Google display ads and they are
inherently different in how you use them
how you set them up and when you use
them
so Google ads launched in 2000 as Google
AdWords and over the years it has gone
through a massive transformation and by
now it is Google's main source of
Revenue
so where in 2000 it was just a search
ads that Google launched by 2005 they
launched the display ads and the ability
to track your conversions of your ads by
2008 Google bought a company called
doubleclick which enabled people and
users to do a much better targeting with
their ads and it also launched the ad
extensions in 2008. in 2013 Google
launched campaign management that you
could run on multiple devices by 2016
Google introduced a showcase shopping
ads
and 2018 was an important year where
Google did a full rebranding of Google
AdWords and as it is now called Google
ads and by 2021 just to put it into a
perspective for you Google achieved a
revenue of 250 billion US dollars from
their advertising business compared to
um
Facebook
advertising in 2021 was around 100 125
billion dollars now don't forget you may
have read in the news that advertising
revenue is um is under a lot of pressure
for the big players like Google and
Facebook because of the economic
downturn that we're going through at the
moment but also because there is a
change in the way Google are going to
allow businesses to track people who are
visiting their website and make it more
difficult to retarget people with ads
when they visit a website but more about
that later but for now important that
you understand Google AdWords has
changed into Google ads
so let's dig a bit deeper in what Google
ads can do for you so it falls under the
category what we call pay per click yep
and that is basically the business model
that Google uses for the Google ads
which is basically when as soon as
somebody clicks on the ad of a of a
company then that com the brand will pay
for the ad we call this pay-per-click
there is also paper impression so as a
brand you would pay a certain amount per
thousand times that an ad is shown to
people but the most common model is what
we call pay per click so a user page or
a brand Pace when users click on their
ads and in digital marketing terms it is
called PPC so very important that you
understand that concept now I often get
a question but what if somebody clicks
they're like a competitor clicks 20
times on my ad would I then pay 20 times
yeah for each click of course not Google
has protected that Google will track
um yeah on illegal clicks on ads and
even if there are Bots that are clicking
on your ad so Google tracks that very
carefully
so then what are Google ads and what is
it so Google ads is an online
advertising platform that develop that
is developed by Google and in that
online advertising platform
advertisers can set up their ads whether
they're being search ads display ads
product ads video ads or app ads and
I'll show you later in the demo how you
can just go to Google ads online to set
it all up there is also a Google ads
editor that you can actually download as
an app and you can create your ads
online and then as soon as you go sorry
you create your ads offline and then as
soon as you go online Google will then
synchronize your ads in the the online
platform
so that is what Google ads is all about
it is an online platform where you can
create and set up your ads so
what are the benefits that you're going
to get from it lots of benefits a very
important benefit is that it will
increase your visibility to an audience
that you can select
yeah one of the big advantages of
digital advertising on Google or on
Facebook is that you can Target very
specific audiences
yes so you can advertise your product or
service to a relevant audience to make
sure that those people perform the
action that you require from them
whether that is a click to buy a product
or a click to register for an event yeah
or a click to download something
a second
advantage that you get from Google ads
is that it is a very effective way to
tell people about your brand
yeah so we call this top of Mind
awareness and particularly with the
display ads and the video ads they are
very important to build this top of Mind
awareness where you're the first one
that comes up in a consumer's mind when
they think about a particular industry
or a particular category
yeah so we have the lead generation we
have the awareness and a third really
important benefit that you get from
Google ads is that you can retarget
website users now what does that mean
you have all received those ads yeah
where you visit the website and then
guess what after 10 or 15 minutes you
are on Google and you see an ad for that
product or you're on Facebook and you
see an ad for the product that you have
just visited or maybe you put your
product in the basket where you wanted
to buy it but then you didn't buy that
product now how do those companies do
that very simple on every page of their
website they put a little piece of HTML
coding
and as soon as somebody visits that page
that's HTML code will trigger a
connection with Google ads or with
Facebook ads depending on the code that
you use and that particular code will
tell Google that user has visited this
page at this time with this device from
this location
and then you can save that data in a
retargeting audience and then you can
select that Audience by creating and
setting up your ads so a very powerful
method to retarget people that visit
your website now over the next few years
this is going to change Google is going
to to stop enabling third parties to
track cookies on people's visits on
particular websites and that will kind
of undermine the whole process of
retargeting so the industry is now busy
finding new ways of retargeting or
targeting people but in the end it comes
down to being very more specific about
the audiences that you want to Target
with your your advertising so watch that
space of the retargeting big changes are
ahead of us
there's more benefits that you get from
Google ads yeah there is a lot of data
that you get there is increased
intelligence that you get you Google
uses artificial intelligence to track
the performance of your ads but turn
that into very relevant data that you
can use to improve your bidding process
as you will find out later Google ads is
based on putting on a bit on what you
want to pay for the ads and then through
an auction Google will decide which ad
will show high up on the Google search
screen now you can and that's best for
the beginners of Google ads you can do
that automatically
you can just tell Google hey Google when
you run this ad you decide on the
bidding this is the budget that I want
to spend you decide on giving me the
best price for the ads given the budget
that I have if you're more experienced
you can go for enhanced cost per click
why you are going to go into manual
bidding based on previous conversion
data and other information like device
model or browser you can then in put in
a manual bit yeah that can help you in
getting a better conversion you can also
do a Target cost per click which
basically means that you adjust your
bits to meet predefined cost per
conversion goals that is quite Advanced
but for the beginners and if you're a
beginner I would highly recommend you to
use automatic bidding where you let
Google do the bidding for you
the next thing that you get which is of
course part of that increased
intelligence as well you can track
everything you can very specifically
measure the performance of your ads you
can determine who clicked on the ads
where did the traffic come from yeah
what is the traffic that came to our
website how many people clicked on my
ads how many leads did I get from that
yeah how many people get to the landing
page and then you get all the data about
what devices are they using what times
did they click on the ad so you can get
a lot of data that can help you in
measuring the performance of your ads
and that's what we'll talk about at the
end of this session where I'll give you
some
um important measuring data that you
want to track
with Google ads you also have a very
high flexibility it has a number of
components to optimize and to customize
your ads and campaigns to Target the
audience that you want to reach you can
specify keywords you can narrow your
audiences you can set negative keywords
very important concept of Google ads is
the the campaign ad Group ads structure
yeah so Google ads has three
Elements which is on the campaign level
an ad group level and the ad level and
the ad inherits the settings of the ad
group and the ad group inherits the
setting of The Campaign so it's very
flexible and when we go into the demo
you get a better idea of how this works
now because you're getting more traffic
to your website
you are also getting an improvement on
your search engine rankings
yeah because more traffic to your
website more pages that Google
recognizes you with the keywords so it
will in the end have a positive effect
on your search rankings
but don't confuse yeah pay-per-click
does not automatically lead to better
search engines a ranking SEO and
pay-per-click are a separate areas but
they do impact each other when you do
active PPC you get more traffic to your
website yeah and that will turn in
higher search rankings if you combine if
you make sure that you have to write
keywords and the consistency in the
keywords
okay so let's dive a bit into Google ads
yeah what are the various formats of
Google ads and there is a wide variety
of ads available that Google built up
over the years but it's not that
complicated at the very first level
there are the text ads they are very
powerful for lead generation
yeah these ads only have text they are
found on the Google search engine result
page
and traditionally you will find him at
the top of the search engine result page
and the bottom listings of the search
engine result page
the quality of your ad and we'll come
back to that later determines
whether you're on the first position the
second to the third or at the bottom
part of your ads
yeah very powerful text ads now there is
a big difference between text ads and
display ads that we talked about earlier
with text ads I have an intent I have a
question I search for answers and if
your ad shows the answer then I'm
prepared to click on your ad so I am
there ready to click on the link that
gives me the best answer whether that is
an ad or whether it's an organic listing
with display ads is different I am not
in Surge mode I do not have a question I
am actually in interest mode I'm reading
an article on a website
so your ad has to stand out has to stop
me or has to interrupt me in what I'm
doing
yeah and only then will I click on your
ads
so text ads have changed and again I'll
show that in the demo later you now have
Dynamic search ads so basically you give
Google in the Google ads settings a
selection of headlines and a selection
of descriptions and then Google will mix
and match the headlines with the
descriptions and try to find the search
ads with the best the best conversions
okay so that is the search ads let's
move on let's go to the responsive
display ads
similar to the text ads that are Dynamic
where Google takes a selection of your
headlines and your descriptions the same
with responsive display ads you put in a
library of
um of uh of of Graphics yeah and a an
image asset so different types of images
and it could be your logo and images
that you want to use in your ad you do
different headlines and then Google will
automatically adjust the size the
appearance and the format of your ads
depending on the space available
yep and there could be an image ad it
could also be a text ad it all depends
on the space available so again you
don't have to create the actual ad you
just put in the creative assets and
Google will create the display ad for
you
you can also say no I don't want that I
actually want to create my own ad and
then you can just create image ads
yourself upload them in the um the the
Google ads platform and then Google will
use those images yeah those ads that
you've uploaded in the different formats
that you created that you've selected
yeah for the website
okay we then have app promotion ads yeah
which is a new
sort of category of ads with the growth
of mobile apps it's very important and a
lot of brands are interested in
promoting their apps yeah I'm promoting
for downloads or engagement in the app
so therefore you can select promotion or
app promotion ads in Google ads and then
Google will sort of add Those ads to the
apps that people are using so those are
the app promotion ads and then you have
a very powerful form of advertising in
Google ads which are the video ads video
ads can be run as Standalone ads on the
YouTube search screens or they can be
inserted in other videos either before
videos or after videos and they can be
skippable or non-skippable and you've
all Seen Those ads when you are on
YouTube you see an ad and then you after
three seconds it will say skip ad
sometimes you see that sometimes you
don't
foreign
very powerful as people love to watch
videos it basically comes down to
putting your ads on YouTube as a video
and then in Google ads you will sign
that video to an ad and there are lots
of examples of really good ads based on
uh YouTube YouTube videos
this is also very interesting for
Content creators if you have a certain
number of subscribers to your channel
and a certain number of viewing hours
you can then qualify for the YouTube
creators program where you can
monetize your videos by allowing Google
to place ads in front or in your videos
and you get a compensation for that so
that is how many YouTubers are
monetizing their business
now an important element I want to add
here is the power of mobile ads
yeah a lot of people are Banner blind we
call this Banner blindness where they
are tired of seeing all those ads on
YouTube and on websites yeah and
particularly in the display and video
ads because they don't ask for it on
Google search it's different
yeah because you have that intent that
we talked about earlier so what people
do on the desktop often they put in an
ads blocker so you don't see any ads so
that means that for Brands their ads on
desktops are less effective they're
reaching fewer people
but since more and more people are
browsing their
um on the internet on their mobile and
particularly video ads yeah and on video
it over on YouTube and on mobile it's
more difficult to put in a an ad blocker
so you'll see that ads on mobile often
have a higher conversion than ads on
desktops
good
then there are the product shopping ads
as you see here on the screen yeah they
pop up at the top of the search result
page where you can actually
advertise your products and that drives
traffic to your product pages now you
need to set up a Google merchandise
store for this and you need to make sure
that you sort of connect your product
catalog from your website with the
Google merchandise store once you've
done that you can then activate the
shopping ads or the product ads there is
also the Showcase shopping ads these ads
have an image and a description that
expands when clicked providing
information about other products and
store information so these are not
necessarily
um
pure product ads but they are
product ads to Showcase other products
and then there is on particularly for
the mobile the call only ads that you
can select
yep and that's sort of concludes the the
variety of ads that you can select from
in setting up your your Google ads
so enough of the theory let's have a
look at the practicalities of Google ads
and let's go into Google ads to show you
how to set up a Google ads campaign to
do that you make sure that you are
logged into your Google accounts you go
and search for Google ads and then you
just click on the Google ads link right
here and that takes you to the Google
ads home page now if you haven't got a
Google ads account you click on get
started yeah and you see a lot of
background information on this page that
will help you with all the aspects of
setting up your Google ads account you
will need a credit card to create an
account that's the easiest way to set it
up if you already have a Google ads
account you just click on sign in and if
you click on sign in it will then ask
you if you have multiple Google ads
account who do you want to which account
do you want to use and I click on my
personal Google ads account and this
will take me to the Google ads home
screen it's kind of your dashboard where
you have a summary of how your campaigns
are running and how they are doing now
you see currently I'm not running any
campaigns so that's why you don't see
any clicks you don't see any Impressions
you see the campaigns that you have in
the under development
Etc it also gives you some advice on how
you can improve your campaigns some
billing information and and what have
you and some other best practice tips
then here you see basically the
interface to the menu functions that you
have remember we talked about the setup
in Google ads split in three areas
campaigns at groups and ads and the
assets of the ads besides that you have
your landing pages your keywords
audiences the content and various
settings that you have and then here you
have search within your Google as
reports that you can create and here you
have tools and settings and there's a
whole library of tools that you have
access to planning tools shared Library
bulk actions measurement setup
where you can for instance specify
access and security and you can see you
can give access to colleagues for
instance in Google ads that they can
edit or view the campaigns there's your
billing information and you can link
accounts as well like your Google
analytics for instance and then you will
see your Google ads data in Google
analytics as well
okay so the easiest bit if I click here
on campaigns or I just gonna click on
create a new campaign and that will take
me to the new campaign setup
and then there is two ways of setting up
your campaign you can either go in
expert mode yeah or you can be guided by
Google and we call this goals guidance
which means you can select what is the
goal for your advertising campaign and
then Google will automatically tailor
all the settings towards that specific
objective so you can have a sales
objective where you want to drive online
sales for instance or in-app you can
create leads yeah so where you can
encourage customers to to click on a
call to action you can drive traffic to
your website you can do products and
brand consideration you can look at
Brand awareness to reach as many people
as possible to promote your app or local
store visits and promotions I'm going to
do a very simple campaign I'm going to
drive traffic traffic to my website
so I click on traffic and then here you
look at your conversion goals do I want
to have page views do I want people to
submit a lead form so I can specify
these conversion goals yeah in my
settings and I'm not going to go into
that now that is a slightly more
advanced element I just click continue
and then it asks me what is the campaign
type am I going for search campaigns
yeah am I trying to reach multiple
audiences so I can go for search and for
display so Google will give you the
maximum performance for your campaigns
am I going for a display advertising
campaign a shopping campaign a video
campaign or a discovery which is running
ads on Youtube Gmail discover and more
the most obvious one of course is the
search and the display or the video
those are the ones that are being used
most and of course if you have an
e-commerce site then you could go for a
shopping campaign so let's set up a
search campaign click on search then you
need to give up your website so I want
to drive traffic to my website riat for
russia.com
and I'm going to call the campaign let's
say winter campaign
click continue
and now I'm going to create
a new campaign start new
yep so now the first step of my campaign
setting is the bidding yeah there's more
campaign settings I can look at my
keywords and ads I can look at my
budgets and my review of the ads these
are the steps that I will be going
through I want to focus my con
my campaign and my bidding on
conversions it is always better to lose
to use the recommendations from Google
for your campaign particularly when
you're new to Google ads am I going to
set a Target cost per action no I'm
going to look leave that Google will do
the bidding for me based on the maximize
conversions bit strategy so Google will
set the bits for my ads which will give
me the maximum conversions on my
campaign yeah so I'm just going to set
that all on automatic I'm then going to
say what networks am I going to use it
is basically I selected the search
network but what Google will also do if
I wanted to to turn my search ad into a
small display ad which gives me a wider
reach of my my ad so that is always good
to leave that default both search
Network and Display Network and then
here you have a very important section
you can set the locations where you want
to show your ad you can do it around the
world you can just look at the United
Kingdom you can also enter a very
specific location I can for instance say
London yep and now I can say London
England United Kingdom so let's pick
that one
yep so now you see my reach is 43
million and 500 people that will see my
potentially see my ad I can also Target
by postcode if I want to include for
instance reading yeah so
rg4
rg40 which is England is reading there
are quite a few of them so I can
actually Target by postcode
yeah so
um if I go further for RG yeah so we
have four and then that could be RG
42 yeah so I can make my section my
segment as big as possible there are
other options as well I can specify
people that are present or are
interested in that location or people
that are just present in that location
or people who are searching for the
targeted location I can also exclude
people so as you can see there's lots of
options in the targeting that you can do
I can go for advanced search you see I
can even specify by map you see here I
have London and here's a bit on reading
that I selected and if I zoom in on that
I can get many more details that I want
to add in there yeah so very Advanced
targeting by local education in the
search ads now you will see in the
display ads the targeting is completely
different you can still Target by
location but you will also be able to
Target by interest of people because in
the display ads you are searching for
websites that people will see your ads
you are selecting websites where people
will see your ads so that can be done by
interest by behavior and by
um by location or you can actually
specifically pick the websites that you
would like to show your ads on you can
specify the language default is English
there are audience segments here's some
basic segmentation that you can do in
the search ads as well for instance I'm
only interested in people that are
having a Infinity with travel for
instance yeah so that's how I can be
more specific in the audience segments
and here are more settings I can do at
rotation so that is where I ask Google
to do kind of an A B testing for me
Google will mix and match the ads and
we'll present the best performing ads
that it finds you can set a start and an
end date you can specify the timings for
your ads the times that it will be shown
my recommendation is to start off with
all day and use the Google learning data
that Google will give you
to improve the edge scheduling at a
later stage you can also do campaign
scheduling
or specific campaign URL options where
you can track your campaigns that is
slightly more advanced and we'll cover
that in a more advanced Google ads
section and then you have Dynamic search
ads you can specify that as well for the
specific targeting and that is quite
Advanced as well so I'll be skipping
that as well now that we've done the
campaign settings we're going into the
ad groups yeah and AD group that we're
having here is the first thing that you
put in there here's the name for the ad
group yeah so I'm going to change the
name into winter campaign
add Group 1
okay so then the very important element
of your ad keywords and your ad groups
is to specify the keywords
yeah and because you've put in your
website Google will automatically go
into your website and it will give you
an example set of keywords that you
could use the best is to come up with a
set of 20 to 25 keywords now these are
the keywords that Google will be using
to match your ad with the search queries
so when somebody searches for react in
Marrakesh yeah then Google will match
that with my ad because in my ad I have
picked riati Marrakesh as one of my
keywords
okay so that um is what you can do here
in your keyword setup
yep in the settings you can see so that
I can show you later you can also
specify your negative keywords but again
this is just for a quick introduction
and then here we're going into the add
creation mode which is the third step of
your campaign so that is where you have
your ads itself now the beauty about
again Google ads it will help you in
coming up with ideas and suggestions for
your um for your campaign here it will
tell you how good is your ad and here
you can see what the ads will look like
now if you don't see anything here very
likely you will have an ad blocker
active
okay so switch the ad blocker off and
then we will see the ads preview and you
can see that on the mobile you can see
how it looks on the desktop so I was
very very convenient and then here you
set up your ads so here you have the URL
which is the final URL where the
um ad will be linking to but there is
also a display URL so I can for instance
say here winter
promotion
yeah so I can basically use the text in
the ads of the link as kind of a
promotion text I can add that as the
text that will help convincing people to
click on the ads where the actual link
could be something completely different
yep and then here you're going to put
your headlines and you can have a
maximum of 15 headlines now Google has
already given some suggestions and you
can have a number of let's say four
descriptions
hmm
you could add images as well
particularly for
um there are ads in division in the
display ads with a rich
um
advertising
yeah so you can add images as well
um particularly for the the display ads
that you may have and then here you have
uh site links yeah so these are what we
call Asset types there are a number of
asset types that you can add to your
campaign yeah to your ads these used to
be called extensions they are now called
asset types so you can do ad promotions
you can add prices or telephone number a
snippet of text a lead form a call out
or apps yeah so these you can add to the
ad and they will show below that
okay but for now this is how I want to
add to look like so I'm clicking done
and I'm clicking next
and now it takes me to the budget
section so here you see it recommends a
budget of 94 pounds now that is a bit
much so I'm actually going to set a
custom budget of a lot lower I'm going
to let's say put it on 25 pounds per day
yes so but you will see that it will
give you a a lower kind of a performance
of course for your ads and this is of
course Google's way to sort of stimulate
you to spend more money on your ads but
my advice is start small yes see what
you get and based on the learnings and
the results that you're getting from
your ads you can start expanding your
budget
so when the ad is ready you're going to
review your campaign Google is going to
check the ad for error for errors yeah
there is an issue I can get more clicks
if I add more site links and more assets
yeah I'm not going to do that now but
here is the review of The Campaign and
when I now click publish
yeah it will go not live yet but it will
go into approval mode for Google yeah
Google will then
analyze your campaign check if
everything is okay check if you're not
breaking any rules or regulations and it
will then publish your campaign based on
the dates that you've specified in your
ad campaign
yep so that is in a nutshell how you set
up an ads now I'm not going to publish
this yeah I'm going to close it I'm
going to save it for later yep and if I
now go back to my campaigns list then
here you see my draft winter campaign
and here you see the details there's
another one an Autumn campaign I haven't
finished that yeah so you see your
budget you see your status and then here
you can also see the results of your
campaign how many clicks did you get how
many Impressions what is the
click-through rate the average cost per
click
Etc all the details that you will get
but since this is just an introductory
to uh introduction to Google ads I'm
going to leave it at this and we will
have a more advanced Google ads video
in the in the future but for now this is
all I want to show you in in Google ads
so let's now have a look at the what you
can measure what is important in the
measurement of your Google ads and how
you can optimize your ad campaigns
so now that you've seen how to set up an
ad let's spend some time on how to
track your ads and Google ads has an
extensive
tracking system in place you can even
connect your Google ads with Google
analytics to get even more detailed
results on your your Google ads but they
all come down to some important metrics
that you need to track so let's have a
look at those there are Impressions yes
so how many times do people see the ads
there is cost there is clicks and
there's what we call the average cost
per click so what are Impressions
impressions are the number of times that
your ad is shown on a search result page
on the Google search page or in the
Google Display Network
now remember for those Impressions you
don't have to pay
yeah you only pay when somebody clicks
on the ads
so when somebody clicks on the ad
yeah then you start paying so there is a
cost involved for that so the cost
reverse to the amount of money that
you're spending on your campaigns
and every time somebody clicks on your
ads it is being charged to your sort of
account and then where you start paying
for your ads so click refers to the
number of times a person clicks on your
ad
and of course that is what you want
unless you want pure awareness you could
do that on Google search yeah but in the
end you want people to click on the ads
that will drive them to your landing
page where they they may then click to
buy your product so that click refers to
the number of times a person clicks on
your ads so if you want to turn that
into a metric you can measure the
average cost per click which is
basically the cost of your that you have
yeah for your campaign divided by the
number of clicks
so if I have 50 clicks
and my cost was 100 yeah my cost per
click is two dollars
that's a very important metric because
of course you want to have as low a cost
per click as possible
now what you can find on the internet if
you search for average cost per click
per industry you will find sort of
average cost per clicks per industry
which can be very useful if you run your
campaign and you will see that can range
anywhere between half a percent to three
four percent
okay so that is your average cost per
click there is also the conversion side
of the business when somebody clicks on
your ad does not necessarily mean a
conversion
when somebody clicks on your ad they
will go to a landing page and on that
landing page you have a call to action
and that could be click to buy or click
to
um to register click to sign up or click
to download that is what we call a
conversion and you can track those
conversions
so the conversions are added when a user
clicks on your ad and performs an action
that you've defined as a goal for
instance signing up for a website buying
a product or registering for a
newsletter or what have you
yeah so those conversions are very
important
and they are of course lower than the
number of clicks that you get
so as you have a cost per click you also
have a cost per conversion
yeah that refers to the average amount
charged for a comp version from your
campaign so you calculate it by having
the cost of your campaign divided by the
total number of conversions
yep and then you have a what we call a
CTR which is the click-through ratio
it's the ratio how often people click
the ad to how often people see your ads
total number of clicks divided by the
total number of impressions
and then finally there is also a quality
score for your ads a quality score is
Google's rating of the quality of your
ads the keywords of your ads that you
use and the landing page and Google
wants there to be a
um a consistency between your ads the
keywords and the landing pages
also called an information sent so when
you smell the ads and you smell the
landing page you kind of smell the same
the same brand the same look and feel
the same keywords the same messages
now this quality score is very important
in that for Google to decide how high
you show up in the Google search ads
page
remember you do a bit on your ads
it's not automatically that the highest
bit will show up highest on the search
engine result page with your ads
Google actually takes the bid that you
put in it adds the quality score of your
ads and it comes out with a total score
and a total score will decide your
position on the Google search page with
your ads so the higher your quality
score the higher the chance that you
will show up at the top of the search
page
so it can well happen that somebody with
a lower bit than you on the same
keywords but with a higher quality score
will show above your uh your ads
Okay so
we talked about the metrics let's now
talk about how do you optimize your ads
in other words how can you make sure
that you have a a higher quality score
because again as I said earlier the
higher your quality score for your ads
the bigger the chance that you're at
will feature on the premium spaces
so very important here are a few of them
you need to make sure that you use
extensions on your ads particularly your
search ads use a call extension or a
review or a price extension yeah there's
a whole range of extensions that you can
select from to add to your ads Google
want to see those
make sure that you test your ads and you
can actually ask Google Google run
various versions of the ads and then
make sure that you use the best ads
which gives the highest performance
people like a sense of urgency in your
ads yeah only three hours left
or 24 hours left for this campaign you
could actually add a countdown timer to
your ad to add this sense of urgency to
your ads make sure that you have calls
to action in your ads yes so people need
to do something they click on the ad to
purchase or click on the ad to register
make sure that you pick the rice
placement for your ad pick the right
targeting for your ads
yeah analyze the timings Google will
give you reports on when people click on
your ads best play best
thing to do when you start a new
campaign is to let Google decide on when
it'll show your ad because Google will
learn from that and will suggest the
best timings to show your ads once it
has gone through this learning stage
make sure that when you run search ads
you can use the location map yeah in
your um to make people aware
particularly for local ads where you are
and very important relate your ads to
what's happening in the seasons yeah so
that could be relate your ads to
Christmas during the Christmas time or
related to
um what's it to Ramadan when it's it's
Ramadan or relate your ads to the World
Cup football yeah when the World Cup
football is on so make them relevant to
the industry
used an accelerated delivery method
Google can help you with that in the the
settings use extensive keyword research
particularly for your search ads
yeah the better your keywords are in
line with the search queries of the
users
the more likely Google will link your
ads with with the search queries use
negative keywords as well
yeah very important that you exclude
certain keywords when you want to use
Google search ads because for instance
if you do a search ad for accounting
yeah when you're an accounting business
you don't want to get people to click on
your accounting business ad when they
are looking for a job
yeah or when they are looking for free
service yeah so you can add jobs as a
negative keyword or free as a negative
keyword
and make sure that you use Dynamic
keywords those keywords they may change
all the time yeah and think about that
um during your campaign you can learn
about your keywords what are the topics
what are the keywords that people use
and you can change those keywords
according what people search for
so there is a lot more you can use
branded keywords as well so make sure
that you use your own company name for
your keywords but if you want to be a
bit naughty there's nothing that stops
you from using your competitor brand
name yeah that when people type in the
name of your competitor that your ad
will show up as well
very important with your cam your search
campaigns that you specify your keywords
in what we call broad match phrase match
and exact match
yeah and
um it depends on what Google how Google
interprets your keywords if you have a
broad match it will show other keywords
in relation to your keyword as well when
it's a phrase match it will make it more
specific and when it's exact match it
will give you an as specifically in
relation to the keywords that you've
specified so broad match will give you a
wider audience so you may get more sort
of
clicks on your ads but they may not all
be relevant clicks where exact match you
will be shown to a smaller audience but
that audience is more likely to be a
lead because you're exactly referring to
what they're searching for
aim for a quality score of 7 between 10
and finally
make sure that your landing page is
mobile optimized is consistent with your
ads it's consistent with your keywords
yeah so it's the ad it's the keyword and
it's the landing page that will
contribute to your quality score
try not to direct people from your ad to
your website
make your landing page unique
make it only focused on the website or
on the call to action that you want
people to do
yeah don't put too many
other clicks on your website the only
clicks that you want to see is the click
for your call to action
we will probably in the future run a
specific session for how to develop
landing pages because it is a very
important aspect of
um of your Google ads campaign
so then there's more there is make sure
that you group and organize your
keywords yeah remember we talked about
the Google campaigns the ad groups and
the uh the the ads yeah so make sure
that you structure your campaign
logically and that you have a clear
structure
around how you're organized now you can
structure it around your products you
can structure it around your locations
you can structure it around the seasons
different ways of structuring your
campaign but make sure you do it
consistently and properly and also use
at the naming structure that you use for
that
yeah make sure that you manage your
budget yeah that you manage it in
relation to your keywords as well and
particularly in the beginning
use automated bidding
yeah let Google do the bidding for you
when you launch your first campaign you
will go into learning modes and Google
will run your campaign but it is
learning and it will during the learning
phase optimize your campaign
yet to make sure that you get the best
results
now I know this is a lot of information
I hope it made clear to you the power of
the Google advertising platform and it's
yeah I'm aware it's been an introduction
to the Google ads platform but if you
want to learn more you'll find a lot
more detail on the simply learned
YouTube channel with more detailed
courses and of course we will in the
future add more current courses on this
topic as well so for now that is it and
I wish you a wonderful day and I'll see
you at the next video
foreign
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here